man accused of killing a patron in a bar
last month will not be getting out of
jail any time soon
twenty-four-year-old anthony balderas
was in court this morning
police say he shot 28-year-old timothy
hartley
at the pt's on decatur near charleston
hector mahi explains why there is
concern
of leading balderas out pending trial
anthony balderas had another bail
hearing tuesday but the judge denied the
request she described this
as an execution killing saying no one
would be safe around balderas
if they were to let him post bond
balderas is charged with one count of
open murder
there is video surveillance of balderas
allegedly
shooting timothy hartley unprovoked
balderas then walked away calmly
he left behind his debit card when
police located him he says he did not
remember
much of what happened his defense argued
there are too many oddities in this case
to go after first degree murder judge
ann zimmerman reviewed the video and
denied a request to set bail
at ten thousand dollars this was her
reasoning
this is an execution this is an
execution
there's no other way to describe it and
your defense counsel argues that there
might be something else going on here
maybe there is but i don't know what it
is all i know at this moment is that
somebody was executed and that you
executed them
both balderas and hartley were said to
be regulars at the bar
authorities say there was no contact or
any dispute between the two prior to the
shooting
prosecutors said hartley was just on the
phone talking with his girlfriend
minding his own business when balderas
walked up
and killed him we also heard from the
victim's sister who asked the judge
to set no bail the next court hearing is
set for august 11th
reporting outside the regional justice
center hector mejia
8 news now